all right
what's up guys mkbhd here and this is an
updated what's in my tech bag
2019 the everyday carry the daily driver
whatever you want to call it this is
that so i've been pretty picky about
backpacks i've had maybe three in the
last
nine years of being a student and
carrying books and things like that that
was always the same type of backpack but
then this one got recommended to me it's
easily the most expensive backpack i've
ever bought but it's very different and
that's kind of what inspired this update
so this is by peak design it's called
it's the everyday backpack that's the 20
liter version there's a bigger 30 liter
one um but this is my everyday carry i
don't need that much space yes i know
there's a matte black version of this
but i got this charcoal one because of
the red accents so i know so with my
previous bags it was kind of like a big
empty space which is great as a
student-minded person with you know
carrying books and stuff like that but
this is divided up it has a ton of
features it's very different so
this is everything that i carry now in
it this is what's in my tech bag 2019.
so i still don't know if this qualifies
as a tech backpack because i mean it
doesn't have any you know battery banks
in it or any solar panels built in
but it has so many features i didn't
realize a backpack could have this many
features it has more than i'll ever use
but it's got all kinds of magnets and
compartments and and latches
and it kind of starts right here at the
top actually you know i'll start with
the smartphones that i carry every day
since people will be asking that um it's
still the oneplus 7 pro as the daily and
the iphone 10s max space gray nebula
blue
those are the smartphone daily drivers
of choice when i'm not testing other
stuff all right so into the bag it's got
this metal latch as you can see and you
pull it down and it sort of unhooks from
any one of these levels on the inside so
if you have a lot of stuff in the bag
you can hook it up to a higher angle
or lower
or lower like that it's kind of great
there's magnets i really like it and
that just exposes the top of what's in
the bag which is just my everyday carry
thing of the day for me that's the
headphones and they are still the sony's
that i've had for the past couple months
i did really like the bose but these are
still my go-to's and then it's kind of
empty you can see like in there it's
it's a good amount of space for that top
third of the bag but if i had more stuff
in there like you know extra shirt or a
jacket or things like that then i would
just sort of latch it up there
it's weather resistant so water just
kind of falls right off the top of it if
i'm in the rain
it's pretty sweet okay so getting
another side this bag is kind of
designed so as you're carrying it you
can take it off and it's got handles on
the side and it's also fully accessible
via zippers on the side so if you want
to like extend it and just kind of have
it like a messenger bag style for a bit
you can do that
and then you get to what's inside the
bag which for me
is a good amount more than i could put
in my previous backpack so you can see
the top third is empty now that the
headphones aren't in there and then in
this middle third this is a camera that
i'd carry every day this used to be the
hasselblad if i'd carried this in my old
backpack it would just kind of be like
loose in the backpack which was kind of
weird so it's great that this is a bag
made for camera stuff and it's more
secure and the camera of choice is no
longer the hasselblad at least for now
i've been really enjoying the canon eos
r and this is the gigantic 28 to 70 f2
lens that they've made for it attached
it's obviously with this lens bigger
than the hasselblad and there's some
things it does better some things it
does worse it's not a medium format 50
megapixel camera but it's much faster it
takes great photos with i mean it's 30
megapixels still it's not like it's soft
and then of course there's all the
advantages of canon they're color
science dual pixel autofocus is very
fast they do a lot of things well i
don't shoot much video at least right
now on the canon eos r i have another
camera in mind actually testing for that
but
that's the camera and the one lens i do
carry in the middle third of the bag
then the bottom third of the bag i have
just kind of the charging accessories if
i was carrying a laptop i would have the
laptop charger down here too but spoiler
alert i'm not either way i have a
battery bank it's more of in case of
emergency because i usually keep things
pretty well charged but this is anker's
26
800 milliamp hour battery which replaced
the 20 000 milliamp hour one i carried
before but all the same features 18 watt
charging usb c in uh and it still has
that little sweet charging indicator and
it's wrapped in a dbrand skin so you can
actually skin your anker batteries now
and uh i have the mclaren edition
oneplus
30 watt charger it's the same as uh the
current 30 watt that comes with the
oneplus 7 pro but it's a little more
fancy orange with this braided cable and
that pretty much takes cares of the
actual insides of the bag you can access
it from either side so if i swap over
here to the other side so you kind of
get used to having the handle of the
camera that you want to get to quickly
always on one side so you always know
where to open it to pull out the camera
and start using it which is pretty cool
and then inside there's actually these
little wings they have zippers in there
and there's stuff that you can put in
these compartments too now like i said i
don't carry a whole ton in the bags so
there you have the uh the one pen i
carry and i think uh have some contact
lenses in there then on the other side
there you go business cards another pen
and a sharpie up here and again like i
got so picky about backpacks but there's
just so many things little things about
this bag that are sweet uh one thing is
the anti-theft zipper so it has a zipper
both at the top at the bottom but if you
want to go ahead and pop this off and
latch it around this here then when
someone tries to yank the zipper down it
won't come off and then these pockets
over here on the side which have magnets
in them to close them they expand and
they're great for an umbrella or
something like that and just to show you
how little of the features i use in this
bag there are so many
latches and things to like attach like
if you want to put a tripod on this bag
you can wrap it around and buckle it in
like that there's also more latches down
here clothes with magnets if you ever
want to do that
i'm probably never going to do that with
this bag because it's my everyday carry
but it's that modular if you want it to
be now you're probably wondering
where's like the computer and all that
main stuff
because i haven't gotten to the top yet
which is the other main compartment so
on the top here there's actually
multiple compartments to fit different
types of computers in the back is the
deepest one for like a 15 inch laptop in
the inside here which is a little
shorter that's the 11 inch ipad pro i've
been carrying that i've been running
that ipad os 13 on
that i kind of still feel like is doing
a job for everything i need it to and
then in the very top there's this little
pouch that's a little more shallow it's
microfiber it has a bunch of small
things in it in there i have a canon eos
r battery i have a mkbhd edition
microfiber which is pretty sweet then a
couple other small things i have the
matte black everything air pods i have
my
vanja uh little flash or sd card reader
i have my
apple pencil here and i have a sd card
reader and at this point the bag is now
empty so it's uh
pretty lightweight and that's the
charcoal and the red and black
and that's what i've been carrying every
day i'm getting on a plane tonight i'll
have my noise cancelling headphones and
things like that with me but other than
that it's not too crazy of a tech bag i
kind of mentioned last time that's like
why i wanted to share it is there's so
many like super high-end
very expensive tech bags out there and
this is a little bit more of a minimal
setup so maybe it'll give you some ideas
for your own or if you want to give me
some ideas for things i do in the future
for my tech everyday carry feel free to
leave them in the comments section below
either way that's been it thank you for
watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace